hey guys so today we're gonna be
examining the five luckiest moments in
my hair Kadeem eeeh so what I means in
practice is that something happened that
was like super unlikely or on the other
hand maybe it was plausible but the
pieces just fell together a bit too
perfectly so to help me go through this
this today is my fellow youtuber shown
in not mistake as I called you in our
last video so this is my Redemption how
you doing man I'm doing fantastic and to
everybody in the comments
giving turtle crap be nice guys but I
appreciates backup
yeah so just so everyone knows I've
listed my top 5 moments Shonen doesn't
know about this so be interesting see
reaction and and then after you've gone
through all that well I think you've
written down like a few members that you
may have that potentially I'm an of
covered I do I have a good one that I
think you might not have thought of okay
okay starting at fifth place the one
that I put down was deku bumping into
gentle criminal just before the cultural
festival so this one had quite a few
coincidences in there so just as one
example the morning of right hatsue may
kind of gives deku the air force gloves
like he wasn't expecting at this time
right so she worked and she gave it to
him before the cultural festival was
over which he wasn't expecting and so
because of that he spent all morning
practicing with them which meant that
when he went to the shops he was you
know later than he expected and then
obviously you know he happens to bump
into gentle at that moment which
wouldn't have happened obviously if he
wasn't late and then because gentle I
think he made a comment about like the
tea he just drank or something and then
it just so happened that Deku had drank
that same tea when he arose he gave it
to everyone this still just fitted
together so perfectly but luckily I mean
it all worked out well because you know
deku was able to save the cultural
festival and everything but what did you
think was that a bit of a lucky moment
or no in your opinion well definitely I
didn't even think about that moment
because I thought it was just
coincidental and is of course needed for
the plot but now I don't think about it
devran lucky definitely necessary but I
wouldn't say that it was like completely
out of the norm
because I mean you just laid out all of
the the pieces right there like you have
like the one little piece at the bot I
don't know if you've seen that mean but
there's like a meme where it's like you
knock one little piece over and then it
just it knocks over a huge pieces behind
it and it winds up being like something
massive so like in this instance it
would be like Deku practicing or Deku
getting his Air Force gloves early and
then the end result would be him like
having this epic fight with that gentle
so moving on to 4th I had so this is the
moment when eda was literally about to
be killed by the hero Achilles Dane and
Dec who shows up like just the right
moment like just before the sustain is
about to kill kill tenure Dec who goes
on this searched through all the
different alleyways of the local area to
see if he can find tenure and listen I
know Dec who's a fast guy but the odds
of him coming at just the right moment
just before his friends is about to die
like that was for tenure at least that
was super I could stencil and yeah
really fortunate what do you think okay
so I'm glad got this this was one of my
minor things I wrote down so we got that
out of the way but I thought about this
a lot myself when I when I rewatched
this sequence because I you know I
always go back time time again watch
seasons 1 through well for now but this
scene I mean the exact thought pattern
ran through my head I was like ok so at
least we have the groundwork here at
least he is actively looking for eda
here I mean it's not like he's just
blindly going around and I don't know
what was his reasoning for exactly
finding he was like I'm just gonna go
and look through the alleyways because
that's where staying attacks people yes
so this was actually like a really good
display of his intelligence so he did
out logic he was like this is the city
where stains attacking and stained he
always attacks in the alleyways and he
could see that Edo wasn't with the guy
who he was interning with so he was like
okay so maybe it is fighting the hero
killer which you know is a bit of a big
leap but it's a logically like there's
there's things to back it up I guess so
that was why he was looking through the
alleyways but um I'm assuming there's
quite a lot of anyway so you know to
come at the right one at the right time
was there's gotta be hundreds I mean I'm
just talking about the city I live in
and then I know even if I could move at
the speed of what what
at this point five percent uh yeah
something like that still removing
superhuman speeds even then you know you
need to have a bit of luck on your side
so this definitely deserves number four
moving on to third place the one I put
down for this was a bit of luck so this
was during the overall arc when
basically the guys they were like
storming forward and essentially I saw
what was about to be pushed into that
room with a rapper and ten guy I saw it
just gets pushed to the side and then
fat guy comes out of nowhere and
literally just saves him I just thought
it was really lucky for I solid because
when we look at that matchup rapper is
someone who doesn't actually really need
his quote to be strong so I saw what
could you know he's up against two guys
gets to look at the guy with the barrier
correct meanwhile rap is there who
doesn't really need his collect a fight
so it would've been a really difficult
matchup I think I thought may not come
out alive and I'm a big guys all were
fine I don't underestimate him
but it would have been super difficult I
agree III was while you were saying and
I was thinking of the possible outs that
he could have had and it's like it's not
looking good because even if he just
wanted to immediately use the capture
scarf unlike rapper or something then
he'd have to deal with the the barrier
which I assume would stop it exactly and
then if he's shutting off the barrier
then he's preoccupied on you know
looking at him stopping the barrier then
trying to use the capture scarf and then
he has to worry about wrap his shoulder
quirk or whatever they mean if it is I I
know that he says it in the volume but I
don't think they say it in the anime
right yeah no they don't I mean just
rotating shoulders probably something
like that yeah yeah I mean I think
that's exactly what it is but man just I
mean you know Aizawa aside from having
his Eraserhead quirk he's basically just
a like a typical person in that world I
mean yeah they have like an enhanced
level of strength and durability because
they're Pro heroes but still like he
probably would have gotten rekt by rappa
in that situation so definitely lucky
that fat gum got out there and stopped
him
falcomon was almost like the perfect
like if they could have picked anyone if
I come probably would have been that guy
because I mean as we saw you know he
absorbed all the punches and then just
gave it straight back so you can also
have to add that to the lock element
here yeah just like that
pretty I mean there's probably other
people that could have taken care of
rapa but not you know the way
that it needed to be done at that time
and it was like even me reading that arc
for the first time in that chapter I was
like how are they gonna get out of this
he's getting destroyed and it's like oh
no wait okay he hasn't out to it it
makes sense because you know that's just
something that happens with character
arc types like that so moving on to
second place everyone I think
accepts that this was a bit of plot
armor which I really loved I wouldn't
take this out the series like I really
loved this moment but it was super lucky
so this happened during season two
during the sports festival when Deku was
facing up against Shinzo in the first I
think it was the first match of the
one-to-one battles and obviously shinzo
brain watches him deck who was told
about his quirk but for some reason I
guess he just forgot and Shinzo
brainwashes him he's walking out the
ring he's about to lose and just before
he takes that final step to you know
lose the match the vestiges of the past
uses of one for all alike now bro you're
staying in the competition and they just
like break his fingers and he stays in
the ring and now when I was watching
this for the first time I was like oh my
god so awesome like this is amazing but
obviously when you're thinking about you
know the luckiest moments I'd say that
would have to be one of the you know one
of the most lucky ever because without
spoiling anything you know in the anime
up to this point we've only seen the
vestiges one more time and that was you
know during the out you know the
post-credits of season 4 so they don't
pop up every day they don't pop up every
week so yeah that was a really lucky
moment for Deku but what do you think so
you bring up that we haven't seen them
and technically we haven't literally
seen them but we have been made aware of
their existence before that point and I
wanted to bring I wanted to loop that
into this moment because this is lucky
for sure there's no doubt about it you
can call it many things like you said
you can call it luck you can call it
shown in but pull plot device armor all
that stuff but I think this openly boils
down to why I think one for all is the
best quirk because they can do this
stuff because like all-4-one definitely
one of the best probably the second best
quirk but it does not have these
failsafe measures built into it the way
that one-for-all does because like I was
saying when we do when we are made aware
that vetches is exists although we're
not exactly aware of what we're looking
at at that point
it's when all my you know taps into the
vestiges power to take out the usj nomu
which does happen in the anime and not
in the manga but I think that's on
purpose because horikoshi was probably
retconning it may be that I mean maybe
you're gonna talk about and then in the
next moment but I think that all my
tapping into the vestige at that moment
is just as lucky as a Zuko tapping into
the vestiges and then making him you
know activate his fingers to to break
them to you know save him from shin so
at that moment I mean it all just goes
back to like wow that is a crazy ability
that seemingly no other quirk is capable
of doing hmm yeah and the thing that
makes it weird with Deku there was the
fact that you know he's brainwashed so
he's not really thinking like he's just
you know he's almost like a zombie I
mean if he didn't have the vestiges on
his side he would have like walk
straight out so they are almost
conscious and were like we need to help
him in this situation
so yeah that is just one of the many
things that makes one floor so amazing
but yeah I guess we should get into the
number one spot so Deku getting the one
for walk work in the first place now we
all know that Deku is a massive all my
fan you know ever since he was a little
kid all he wanted to be was just like oh
my and then one day you know he gets
attacked by the start villain and who
saves him all might okay so that's a bit
lucky in itself and we could have just
left it there but then a series of
events that occur after that that lead
to Deku getting the power of the guy
that he admires most in the world and
what's crazy is that he was actually
offered the power on the same day that
he just happened to bump into him like
what a crazy day like waking up that
morning quickness and then going to bed
that night knowing oh I'm gonna get the
power of my favorite hero so I consider
this to be like the luckiest things
happen to anyone ever in my hair Kadima
or in the real world is actually just
saying absolutely I I knew this was
gonna be number one and if not I was
gonna be number one I was gonna be
number two because it is it's insane
that this happened and I thought just
like I was thinking about the other so I
thought about this too I was like wow
how lucky is it for him a zoo coup to
run into his idol conveniently and then
also get his power at the same time
become his protege I mean just the I
mean cuz like yeah all my is in Japan
and stuff like that but
like he's not like always we're a zoo
coup is like even him showing up people
were like oh my God all mighty roar how
unexpected I mean also he was there
because he I mean also he was like in
the general vicinity because I don't
remember the exact timeline but I know
that he was going to try to go talk to
me Rio or something and it wound up that
you know he went ran into a zoo coup
instead but still had happening
regardless the probability is insane
yeah I mean it would have been lucky to
just meet all my in the first place like
that first encounter that they had you
know he gave him the autograph and
everything if it ended at that that
would have been lucky in itself so the
fact that it then continued on to all
you know everything else that happened
is pretty crazy
and I think sometimes I wonder like how
much would the time might have changed
had this you know coincidental meeting
not taking place I just imagine it'd be
such a sad series at that point because
Muriel would get one for all most likely
and then easy coud just stays Quercus
watching Baku go go on to be the number
one student at UA it would just be so
sad I feel like Deku would become a
Vedanti though obviously has a quote
this guy there's any so far you can go
with that stuff right exactly but I mean
I I think it is fair to say that he
would have did something like that and I
think that would have also made for an
also an interesting story seeing how a
quark less human can actually try to
become somewhat of a pro hero you know
officially or not yeah much to think
about much to think about
but um moving on so I've listed my five
what are the ones that you have that
maybe I didn't mention alright so here's
my biggest one we'll just start off with
this one and this is kind of gaggy
kind of skillful but undeniably lucky
alright so we're gonna go back to when
you were talking about the whole thing
about the zoo coup showing up where eita
was with the whole stain thing well
we're just gonna go a few sequences
after that because a zoo coup
straight-up takes his phone out puts it
behind his back with with gloves on and
somehow texts his location to Todoroki
yeah and then totally gets there yes yes
close alone how did he do that it's
pretty crazy no it's one of
it's one of the most impressive feats in
the series easily yeah oh for sure for
sure because first of all just text
behind your back
that's a friggin crazy achievement in
itself but then you have those thick
hero gloves on that he has like they're
not made for cellphones they're for
fighting and stuff yeah
Oh what what I'm thinking about it why
did I even need to put it behind his
back I mean it's not like the hero
killer would have I don't why do you
need to do that I don't hate put that
and what heroes don't use Oh exactly
yeah
like what would have happened if you
didn't do oh that's actually a good wow
that's a really good one
all right so another one we got in the
beginning of season three token the army
goes on his rampage seemingly no one can
stop him at this point he's just way too
powerful for even the vanguard action
squad and the students the only one that
would really be able to stop him at this
point is Isiah but conveniently Todoroki
and Bach over there with the light to
stop him and I always thought that like
okay so they could have easily not been
there there was a whole bunch of little
groups and people going on they could
have been knocked out by the gas you
know a whole bunch of things would have
happened for them to not be in the area
where Tokyo Yami was rampaging so like
if they weren't there like what would
have happened you know I always thought
about that no no that's actually a
really good point because I mean there
was so many students who weren't there
so the idea that yeah specifically
Totoro came back ago are the ones that
show up yeah that is pretty lucky
actually and if they weren't there I
mean I guess he would have just
continued on his rampage err I mean the
thing about when he was in that form is
that he was attacking people like
indiscriminately like it didn't matter
who they were so I feel like he would
have been more of an asset to the
villains at that point if he kept on
rampaging rather than the errors exactly
I mean unless he didn't get in touch
with hold of them cuz as soon as he like
grabbed moonfish he was done I mean he
was exited from the series after that
point yeah but that's all I got and ya
know well thank you for coming on the
channel man those are some really good
ones especially the gloves won't light
look into it guys if you haven't checked
out Shonen already then do be sure to
check out his channel he's on the road
to 60k he's almost there so if you can
subscribe to not be massive thanks
thanks for watching guys and
peace out